este domingo ciudadanos de la capital
del país y de otro centenar de ciudades
en México y en el extranjero se reúnen a
la convocatoria de más de cien
organizaciones para rechazar las
modificaciones a las leyes electorales
básicamente Salvador porque está usted
Bueno pues han sido muchos años de
construir un sistema electoral
decente y
confiable y pues nos negamos a que esto
se acabe que lo terminen
por esa es la razón de acuerdo el
presidente López Obrador ha
descalificado esta concentración ha
dicho que Quienes se reúnen en realidad
buscan defender un régimen de
privilegios que son conservadores Marta
qué diría al respecto
el presidente nos ha tratado de
desacreditar desde que llegó esta
muestra y esta expresión ciudadana
confirma lo contrario no venimos a
defender la corrupción venimos a
defender al INE Muchas gracias esa es el
motivo por lo que se congregan aquí
porque consideran que las reformas
debilitan al organismo electoral y ponen
en riesgo la certeza de las elecciones
pero ahora será la suprema corte de
justicia de la nación la que tome la
última palabra para responder a estas
impugnaciones que buscan frenar estos
cambios a la legislación
[Música]